after President Trump heralded the new
jobs numbers in the Rose Garden today
the media engaged in such a disgusting
perpetual smear job that we felt that
was our duty to call it out and the
perpetrators the claim was best
summarized by Bloomberg News reporter
Eric Wasson he said Trump says he hopes
George Floyd is looking down from heaven
and happy about the strong jobs numbers
well that is a lie and that lies spread
like wildfire among more prominent
members like CNN's Jake Tapper and the
New York Times Peter Baker it even made
its way onto the cable airwaves on MSNBC
Michael Steele former RNC chair that's
embarrassing called Trump's comments
borderline blasphemous now if the
President had actually said what those
media members were alleging then his
comments would be out of place and I'd
call them out but since we won't lie to
you here's what Trump said in its
entirety equal justice under the law
must mean that every American receives
equal treatment in every encounter with
law enforcement regardless of race color
gender Acree they have to receive fair
treatment from law enforcement they have
to receive it we also what happened last
week we can't let that happen
hopefully George is looking down right
now and saying this is a great thing
that's happening for our country there's
a great day for him it's a great day for
everybody there's a great day for
everybody this is a great great day in
terms of equality it's really what our
Constitution requires and it's what our
country is all about
he's talking about equal protection
under the law regardless of race joining
me now
Charlie hurt Washington Times opinion
editor former New York Post White House
correspondent Fox News contributor
Charlie did you hear that jobs report
mentioned in there how do the media
figures who I called out justify the
blatant dishonesty and what they did I'm
mad about this you know it you know it's
it's not even a distortion of what he
said because they're always destroyed
what he says this is a flat-out lie he
didn't they're they're making up
something that he simply did not say if
you listen to his actual words he's
giving a shout-out
he's applauding the peaceful protesters
writing or protesting the treatment of
George Floyd that is entirely different
100% completely factually different from
what the what people are claiming he
said but if you stop and think about it
and you go back to the beginning of just
this year this guy has been through an
impeachment which was entirely made up
of lies and then all of the stuff before
the impeachment was made up of lies the
guy's been through a pandemic he's going
through riots right now and the good
news the good economic the stunningly
good economic news that that came out
today I think has a lot of these people
in vapors I think that they're they've
got nothing left to do but to make up
things about Donald Trump and between
now and the election law we're going to
be listening to exactly this sort of
thing where these guys come unhinged and
make stuff up every single day yeah I
mean Charlie they thought the Muller
investigation was going to save them
then they thought impeachment was going
to save them then they thought the virus
was going to save them now they think
the the protests and the riots are gonna
save them and I think each time you're
like wait a second this guy is really
resilient and I think they're freaking
out about it I think they're absolutely
freaking out and they don't and it's
going to get worse I completely agree
with you now the media's lies they have
real political consequences here with
Biden toward the end of his remarks
President Trump said he hopes that quote
George Floyd is looking down and seen
this is a great day for our country for
the President to try to put any other
words in the mouth of George Floyd I
frankly think it's despicable Charlie
your reaction you know I mean with me
with a media like this you know it can
you kind of wonder well what else
do you expect but you know you what you
said in your angle is exactly right
about this you know all of these
predictions it's not only the lies after
the fact it's all of the prognosticating
before the fact
we're from Russia to impeachment to the
pandemic to all of it the the
predictions have have been the most dire
predictions they're their fever dreams
their dreams about anything and and and
ultimately what it is is it's rooting
for failure they they not only want
Donald Trump to fail they want America
to fail that they would do anything they
will crash any economy they want the
city to the country to burn to the
ground aren't at all anything to yet
just to blame Donald Trump and and so
now that all of these things all their
predictions aren't coming to fruition
they've they're left with nothing else
but just to lie after the fact and
they're gonna keep doing it and they're
gonna and and and I and you know what
the American voters are very very cagey
and they're very smart and even people
you know that they don't get paid like
you and I do to pay attention to all of
this all the time and you know we you
know live it day to day they can tell
when people are lying and I don't think
it's going to work in this election
never it's never seemly to be rooting
against your own country or your own
country's demise now we see that in a
lot of the protesters the activists the
violent violence and it's not good there
are good protesters and a lot of bad
stuff going on in between charlie thank
you so much